with a head of hair that can literally  stun this is the curly hair tarantula  [Music]  the unusual hairs on the curly hair  tarantula are both its most  distinguishing feature and its best  weapon when threatened it will kick  hairs of its abdomen that blind looming  predators found throughout Central  America this borrowing species is found  in scrubland nocturnal by Nature  the curly hair tarantula is an  opportunistic hunter ready to eat  whatever passes by this spider has  extremely poor eyesight but at the end  of its legs are receptors that are  sensitive to smell taste and vibration  once the tarantula detects its prey it  injects paralyzing venom through two  hollow fangs despite their popularity in  the insect pet trade wild curly hair  tarantulas are at risk due to habitat  loss in Central America this is the  curly haired tarantula  [Music]